To find the treble clef, I started by
going to the musical symbols section
because well, that just makes sense.
Looking through all the characters,
it looks like there is
a treble clef right there.
And, wallah.
There is its HTML-code,
right here for easy copy and pasting.
I'm testing out the treble clef
by pasting its HTML code here.
And then observing what happens
on the site over here, and
notice there's the treble clef.
So, clearly this HTML code is working.
By the way, this is just the same koala
website you saw a few minutes ago.
This looks good.
But, I wonder what would happen if
I just simply pasted the treble
clef itself into the html,
remember it's just a normal character.
So I will copy it and
I will paste it right here.
Now look, I've got the treble
cleft over here in the the HTML.
And I've got the treble
cleft in the site.
This is nice because these two match.
In fact,
it's actually recommended to copy and
paste the actual Unicode
character into your HTML.
It's easier to read and maintain.
So, the correct answer is,
ampersand pound sign and
then the number that you see here.
That's the HTML code for treble clef.